we know there are other stories to tell
but we've never felt the pressure
to push them out there until we feel
like there is a great story to tell and
that we have something
that again will be a worthy entrance to
the
conjuring universe i'd like you all to
sit quietly and close your eyes
[Music]
i really wanted country three to get
away from the haunted house set up
of the first two conjuring films it
should be more on a
whole different level something that
we've never explored before in the
conjuring world we wanted to
keep our new story grounded in the feel
of conjuring movies
but we wanted to make sure we were
telling a brand new story and we think
the arne johnson story
was something that really deserved a
much closer look
as i got to the bottom of the stairs and
i went to open the door
i don't remember anything from that
point the next thing i know
i was in a jail cell and i said what's
going on here
and they say well you're being charged
for murder i said
what are you talking about
[Music]
the trial of arne cheyenne johnson this
was an internationally
renowned case which was the first time
in the history of law in the united
states that
that demonic possession was used as a
reason for committing
manslaughter do you think you'll be able
to prove the existence of the devil in
court
truth doesn't require anyone to believe
in it you're in for a much different
ride than you've been on in other
conjuring films what's the point of a
sequel if you can't out
shine and out story and outheart
the previous films it just requires you
to bring
your a plus game when i was working with
michael shoves on la yorona
i saw a filmmaker that really gets these
kind of films
it's bittersweet for me to pass the
baton on
and action but it's good to get a fresh
take
on where we can take the conjuring
universe we're offering something very
special
with these films and i think that's one
of the reasons people keep coming back
the final reason of course is that
people love to be scared i don't know
that anybody has
crafted or created better scare
sequences than
james wan david sandberg gary dauberman
corn hardy john leonetti michael chavs
guys we're making contra and three it's
gonna be awesome these are all people
that really know what they're doing and
they do an incredible job
crafting new and original scare
sequences that's really what people come
back to see
you